قالت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه انالينا
بيربوك ان المعاناه التي وصفتها بالمرو
التي يعيشها الابرياء في قطاع غزه لن
تغادر مخيله احد واضافت انها تقوم بحمله
مكثفه من اجل وقف اطلاق النار في غزه
لاسباب
انسانيه نرى المعاناه المروعه التي يعيشها
الابرياء في غزه هذه الصور لن تغادر مخيله
احد المباني التيص حت مجرد هياكل حديديه
والطريقه التي يبحث بها الاباء عن اطفالهم
تحت الانقاظ وصور الاطفال الذين يجلسون في
المستشفيات في حاله صدمه لهذا اقوم بحمله
حثيثه من اجل وقف اطلاق النار لاسباب
انسانيه في الاسابيع القليله الماضيه لم
اقم باجراء الكثير من المكالمات الهاتفيه
فحسب بل تحدثت ايضا الى مجموعه واسعه من
الشركاء حول كيفيه تنفيذ وقف اطلاق النار
الانساني من حيث المكان والتوقي
لان اهل غزه يحتاجون كل شيء الماء والخبز
والرعايه
الطبيه